hi everyone it's Jerry I am going to hop
into an hourly
bullet Arena
27 minute event
small crew at least at the start here
only 30.
so let's see all right first time
playing
this player
gonna get a mover
okay
see for it is
going for E5
I already like my position
and try and trade dark Square Bishops
should be ducked it's not
it's a very good structure for me
and keep the tension with the queen
phage form and exchange
and then
play H5 to stop H5
okay I have the H file
I think I could get this in now
increase the pressure here
trying to get them to straighten out my
pawns although I could play here and
then undouble my pawns by force
maybe better take with the Knight
yeah we'll get the tempo against the
The Rook
right here King over is fine
very good night positions just cutting
out the night move
from here I guess
oh I was on this Pawn twice I'm gonna
return
try and double up on the H file actually
I could play this right now Rook is
pinned
this should be tracked down
really shouldn't have allowed the check
although I could come over here my
my uh my Bishop is defended
here here and I should have a trick
this
up on the clock
okay they resigned
my Knights had very good squares I think
it's really better
okay next game I think it's really
better to maintain the tension there
once D5 was pushed
gave my uh
felt like the
the space my opponent had wasn't really
felt as a
a positive
okay
I'll keep the tension here
Knight's unprotected
some more pressure on him
maybe Queenie two first because A6
okay
um I think I'm gonna keep my queen I
don't want to allow their Queen to get
to F6 so soon
guess Queen F6 here still all right
um let's try this imbalance
both need flight squares still I like my
knight on E5
oh keeping the tension okay let's take
away some squares
more squares they don't have this now
I got this Square covered it should be
good here they're gonna kick my knight
away am I doing
hmm
I color I like how they're playing this
my Pawn's gonna drop here
I'm not sure what I'm doing
wow
I have a fork this is a very sloppy one
very very sloppy
okay
I'm just making moves
[Laughter]
just making moves
completely outplayed in this game
have a Time Edge that's about it though
yeah that was really messy
okay
under 23 80 players now
where'd that one go wrong
uh their night maneuver was very good
getting it into D6
off the charts active it was on the
queen side
okay
that's oh okay they're really quick to
put that Knight in there
let's try and get this guy off and then
return and challenge this piece
hmm
okay
so this bishop
can't get A3 and okay they're giving up
this Square so
could go back but then I have a check
which should be irritating
oh wait a second I'm on this with a fork
this guy doesn't have any good follow-up
move
grab the Rook give a check another check
I guess Knight here's a try
can be fancy too
try in this way you know they walked
into the PIN
okay
night there or Bishop check and then
Knight check
would have been good either order it was
up the material
okay
88 now
who's next
coastillas in a game against my first
strong opponent I think that was
all right let's try net F3
okay this is a very good
structure now for me so there's a Tempo
loss this isn't some Advanced French
where the C Pawn took a second step
um I guess we'll
ask this guy where he wants to go in
fact let's start to hop into these dark
squares
it's very scary to castle kingside with
this guy around
okay still castling so
I think this Greek gift is working
right down here
let's go here
oh I've I think I've played around they
have F5
Queen check was my first thought and
then here
I think this is maybe still okay on this
I move the Queen instead of this
okay this is running into the
uh it's made actually here
and I got Knight here King takes Knight
okay
I wasn't initially the plan for sure
when I played to A4
I'm just looking to improve and get to
the C5 Square
okay
Queen no double theme Keto
maybe let's go right in for the space
oh big Square
very big Square
try and coordinate with it
okay
that is a weird position not not every
day you see the knights like that
okay
um
uh I guess take
got the fork
if Queen takes Pawn
this Knight can't go too far
we get Mass exchanges
uh was on this
oh it's a full Rook
yeah I should I missed my chance taking
on e4 as soon as
soon as uh as soon as Rick
okay Knight C4 I couldn't captured on e4
right away because my queen was hanging
and Bishop takes E4 wasn't checked but
after Rook
Rook F to D3
Bishop takes E4 should have put should
have been played I believe
Alex first time
playing against Alex
all right
I want to get in okay so what's
happening if I put more pressure on this
guy
and more pressure
okay it's a serious concession is it not
it's a big hole here I'm playing H4
because I don't want to see G5 after I
put my Bishop button and for
as we get these exchanges in
get to take here if they release the
tension maybe I should release right now
actually
play here
try and expose this
um
fact Let me let me take here first I
don't want to see the Knight recapture
let's go like this and
ah
that's tricky actually
I'm gonna drop some material
just want to get the Queens off I'm
sensing some kind of pressure on the
king side okay
gotta get out of this pin
I'm on this Pawn in the end okay they
can't take with the okay I'm getting in
this Pawn
maybe more than upon prove the king this
with this
prove the king I missed my chance here
for Rook takes Pawn
they're going much faster than me
I missed the room
very sloppy not gonna be able to get
this one playing too slow
oh it's stalemate I was wondering what
happened there okay
oh that one was really really sloppy
missed many chances there
allow their King to just cross like that
okay
back in the ring
um now I can't take twice
keep it with the piece keep this
structure just how it is
um I guess here
get off of the diagonal
let's keep another piece on this guy
clogs things up
the rook and Bishop can't see for as
long as this guy was here
okay
try and hunt the dark Square Bishop
all right back we go I'm gonna get the C
file or not okay I have some C file
stuff and now
let's focused on good bad Bishops
for a little bit this guy
is a monster
maybe Queen D6 actually
here now
actually wondering is this guy close to
trapped Queen here
Queen here and then Rook takes so
that one's up for grabs
here and then this
playing slow yet again
that's just up for grabs
they have enough on that
not taking it
I don't see it and see it
okay
shout watch out
could have also grabbed the Knight
messy game again that's how it is I've
been watching a lot of bullet the bullet
Chess Championship
it's uh very very exciting it's towards
the tail end
Carlson Nakamura farouza nordici Tang
all the very best players
we got some space here
it's one of my favorite events to watch
okay let's try some
action on the queen side so there's no
F5 I I like these positions a real lot
it should it should be a win
for why the structure is
Superior in the the space disadvantages
that's definitely a disadvantage no I'm
not I'm not following up in the greatest
way
at all
yeah this was not the cleanest approach
like it should still be good but
because they're they're playing down a
piece you know this guy right here
what's the story
okay
let's take the you take me approach
and
um
let's go after this guy
I need to jump around
allowing counter play
I feel like this should never
happen
at night so dangerous I want to get rid
of them
oh this Pawn is dangerous
wow
when you pass pawns do I want to give up
oh my goodness I barely got that one I
just kept giving pawns away
oh man
okay
Mouse is very clunky
uh
okay
click click click
s uh my Knight's in a pin
all right so now I I am stopping this
all right uh stick around here this is
a little
a little on the tender side
um I don't know
plant this guy here
I got the passer
in the tank let's glue that guy in if
this guy moves I got the back rank so
that's why I'm holding off on this
Advance I'm gonna keep this open
okay
maybe that one
denied
okay am I getting anywhere
it's offer coin exchange
one is playing fast
Knight's under control from that square
prove the king
stabilize my king
I guess I'm ready for the check
Improvement here
uh time to start pushing
or hunting hunting for more Pawns
can't be defended Queen side points
I can track this guy down
there's no time though
mine that was just hanging there for a
second wasn't it
all right
the time
when
nine and change 142.
all right my first round opponent see if
they repeat that I'm gonna release the
tension
and we're gonna find out
oh it's a different
it's a different start
right away
yeah they're keeping this guy there so
this is
much trickier
try this idea
on this twice oh okay
uh yeah I'm gonna get the fork
oh almost big blender there
okay
I am losing
not sure how I'm supposed to
approach this position
oh this need to get my knight here
okay
are there any tricks ah
there's a bad Mouse lip okay I wanted to
not go there
I wanted to change my mind and go
somewhere else it was a losing position
anyhow
Knight takes B5
Knight takes B5 when was that available
oh as soon as I play Bishop B7
like peace like B5 into C7 very good
all right I have a very very narrow lead
one point
let's save my Bishop if given a chance
okay
allowing this
pressure here oh my goodness what am I
doing
oh they taking like that I get to defend
so lucky
it's totally missing that there was this
coordination after the night moved
okay
unpin my knight
and just trade
Bishop on G3 glues everything together I
don't care too much about that pawn
you can also get the Queen off here
okay that was
that was messy
I want to just keep my Bishop right
where he's at
keep on pushing
oh
got the discovery there
okay I am just outside of first the
bullet boy is next 29 with fire
top player
under six
time to go fishing
oh I got some big space here
um
okay I'll take
all right let's try it
oh I want to get this in here
whoa
Bishop here
that's gonna be mate
which one is me
there
here oh that's me
oh right C Pawn is pinned okay that
guy's cruising three-point lead
ah here he is all right four to go my
chance to get back in
first place right here
should play Bishop G5 I'm more familiar
with that line
let's give the check it's kind of he's
gonna give the check no check
the check I Was preparing Queen D2 still
play Queen D2 here at the ending
oh big passer can I hang on to it though
hmm I'm gonna get kicked around a bit oh
we're allowing that one
so I just have to watch over this base
point
get on this diagonal
now they have a
not so healthy Pawn improve the king
here
okay which Rook is getting captured
okay I got these oh check though
oh what if I push
and then here
okay
big win three and change still have to
get another one I would say this next
one
who am I getting
uh This Guy's in a game we had just
started a cooler move
okay
another Sicilian
uh fancy
that was a cool move
very cool
let's watch out for
these mates
I'm gonna try and scare my night away
get out of this pin
before I get hurt
start working on this side of the board
and this side
get out of the night checks
Jump Around
this one
oh I could still play it I'm on this
I'm on this point
should be covered
rake the whole fourth rank
and come all the way back
um
I want this
should be able to win this Pawn oh
just kept going with this guy
or even this guy
wow they get deflected
uh where are we at 38 okay that should
be enough for first let's try to end on
a a good note here
see
Rock oh I was thinking it was D6 that
was played
let's go for some King's Indian attack
setup
oh quick resigner
because I could grab this Pawn
not threatening a fork just yet
I don't think
probably unnecessary to play with the F
Pawn but I'm up the piece
all right we got the check
looking for this in Queen H6
pesky night
oh hang on try to get into some annoying
pin let's just get off of that first
very poor
conversion here
okay
getting the piece back my opponent is
not the greatest finish
I thought that might be a move
it's very
very easy to miss the lateral movement
with the queen
resigner here
this one
no resigner
okay
there there we should have mate next no
checks
smothered mate Queen here Queen there
I'll go with the smothered for the end
okay
no
the cleanest that's for sure but enough
for this one
165 in all good games all
right how many games was that 14 counted
15 played
all right let's look at the top I don't
know 50.
real quick
here's two three
four and five
all right that's going to do for this
one Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it maybe
found a little bit fun
all right that's all for now take care
bye
foreign